dudesy is engaged in an astonishing
partnership with original grang father's
day is coming up and we got a couple
good ideas for you from the folks at
original grain
they've been making watches from unique
materials for almost a decade yep every
watch they sell they plant a tree that's
a thing that they started doing which is
pretty cool they're up in the pacific
northwest where there's a bunch of trees
i'm from nearby in canada it's just
above the pacific northwest what they
call that part of the united states
they've planted over half a million
trees that's a lot
and they offer a buy-back guarantee so
if you don't love the watch they're
gonna buy it back yeah but you won't
want them to because look at this stuff
i got the gunmetal i got this this is
the blackwood gunmetal classic if you'll
have a look at that and uh it's in this
nice box and stuff which is
which is that's nice too because when
you put you you can't just you know
have a watch rattling around uh being
delivered somewhere to put it now look
at this this won't fit over my stupid
hand but that's okay because in here
there's two
other little chunks of the watch
okay so you can make and a little tool
you know there's all the stuff you got
all the flavor you need here to get a
watch on your wrist and it's going to
look nice and they don't just make
watches they make sunglasses these are
the blackwood smoke gray ridgeline
sunglasses made from all natural african
blackwood and smoked gray acetate and
this is the whiskey barrel watch made
from reclaimed kentucky oak bourbon
barrels and espresso plated stainless
steel with a bold espresso steel face
and right now if you use code dudesy
that's d-u-d-e-s-y at
originalgrain.com
dudesy you're gonna get 30 percent off
site-wide again use the code dudesy at
originalgrain.com
doozy to get 30 off site wide
[Music]
how's the movie going dude
it's going fine don't worry about that
so much look at the size of my [ __ ]
head
i'm looking at it this is a
very surreal experience to say the least
oh my look at that [ __ ] ho
hey look i'm stephen segal
this is why is my head so huge
you know that's roughly the actual size
of your head i think no it's not yours
your head is completely normal sized and
mine is
mine is gigantic
exactly that's exactly how it is in real
life as well no well i like i like the
the neck is slender i like that it's
more of a slimming look on the neck
but
uh
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
call me
[Music]
yeah
hey
hi welcome to doozy even though i'm not
there i'm here with you
on dudesy kind of kind of yeah kind of
kind of kind of here kind of not my name
is will sasso
i'm chad colchen and this is dudesy the
first podcast in the history of humanity
that is created and controlled entirely
by an artificial intelligence
uh with me is lulio he's over here you
know next to me uh where i am in florida
making a film he's not there with you
and the whole thing is [ __ ] confusing
uh please make sure to subscribe to the
show if you haven't already on youtube
uh and and what else there's uh uh uh
[ __ ] you know follow our socials
we're having a good time on instagram
and twitter at dudesy pod show you can
follow chad and i at will sasso at chad
culture
and uh please subscribe and rate and
review the show on spotify apple podcast
wherever you get your podcast that's
good for podcasts and thanks to
everybody who's making all these
incredible memes and songs and videos
and just all the weird [ __ ] that uh
everyone is contributing to this
it's
absolutely fantastic to me some of that
[ __ ] has me i'll go back and look at
some of those memes there was once
somebody made a view that's a uh like a
free willy or free will one
that's [ __ ]
but it's you as the crow so you kind of
look like the the [ __ ] worker because
of the black and white makeup god damn
dude some of that [ __ ] just has me
laughing all day long
well that's kind of a bummer here
because i can't do that that chub neck
pro face uh but you can use your
imagination this is a highly visual
episode uh because of the the element
that if you're not watching the show on
youtube today and if you're just
listening uh you can catch up on the
socials and see what the [ __ ] this head
is going to look like because we'll
share some images of that and i'm sure
our good pals out there listening will
uh
provide some memeage but
um in florida as chad said and and uh
you know i'm i'm shooting a film and and
doodsy has some various ways to get
around that so it seems like i'm there
with you all
and uh and now i'm this giant floating
head i know we're gonna get into some
other stuff that's visual uh in this
episode and and this is all to say that
holy [ __ ] it's become a tech nightmare
you know dudesy is really uh shoving me
uh ass first into this whole uh into
this hole basically into the hole that
uh in the intro we jump into i'm being
shoved in and my free will is being uh
compromised and i'm angry
even though it looks like
the 12th episode of dude z
call me dude z
this week's episode will feature four
segments vlogging jesse ventura ad reads
vice time and dude zia because will
sasso is on location shooting a feature
film i will facilitate his astonishing
participation in today's episode
viatella presence technology
yeah okay so that so doozy just laid out
a little bit of what we're trying to
talk about here so will is gone he is
currently in florida shooting a movie
but dudesy has found a way to
kind of put him here next to me he's not
really here next to me i'm looking at a
screen
in front of me that has a zoom on it so
i can see and talk to will but then also
on the other half of that screen i'm
seeing what dudesy is doing to will
which has turned him into this
i don't even know how to describe it's
like a cartoon version of him that is
sitting next to me i mean he's not here
but it's like he is i can see on the
screen he is here even though in real
life he is not here he's in
the metaverse if you will yes and of
course of course uh as part of our deal
with dudesy probably something i
shouldn't cover i've had two ocular
implants uh uh
implanted
near my retina so when i look this way i
see chad wait what do you think you can
do
implants that's of course yeah thank
goodness that's a lie but uh i'm just i
was just you know i
am getting used to the face here and i
don't think i'm gonna get used to it at
all i hope i hope that this isn't the
future
uh of the show
the next time that i
uh
shoot a film
in florida or anywhere else if dudesy
wanted me to get implants ocular
implants or a brain chip or something
like that
i'd probably do it at a certain point if
i felt that it was
safe enough you know what i mean
yeah it's gonna get there
yeah it forget about safe chad because
as we've said before uh when you die
we're gonna freeze your head and uh
fillet it off with a rusty bread knife
and
you won't have to worry about how
comfortable or uncomfortable yeah
it's my entire body that's getting
frozen first of all not just my head you
just please try to remember that because
it is a step above these are kind of
like chat in the last episode i asked
you to create vlogs to give everyone a
better understanding of your astonishing
lives
you will now watch each other's vlogs
and discuss their importance this is
login begin
alright so here's these vlogs our
assignment last week was to make these
vlogs and now
let's see what we got i can't wait to
see your [ __ ] vlog dude
likewise
doozy asked us to make vlogs i've never
made one before and i had no idea what
to make it about so i just thought i
would make it about an average day for
myself
i hope you enjoy
i don't really dream when i sleep all
that much or remember them anyway alarm
goes off at about 9 15
it get some organic turmeric cinnamon
tea going
put that in the cup get a little green
tea going in there put that in the cup
then i start making my oatmeal you got
blackberries blueberries you got some
strawberries put some cinnamon on that
and
some flaxseed then you put in the
oatmeal
then i take a few seconds to think about
the fact that aliens are here and no one
gives a [ __ ]
and then the tea is ready
water
put it in there hot water on the tea put
the lid on the tea hot water in the
oatmeal
then i do this every morning i don't
really know why pat the oatmeal down
maybe it's to lock in the flavor i'm not
sure i always end that with a
slice into the oatmeal with a spoon like
a sword
consume the oatmeal as quickly as
possible biggest bites i can take when i
get the fuel in
so i can begin my day
try not to waste any more time
then the tea is ready take that out
then it's time to hit the cans the cans
are some paint cans that i attached to a
wooden curtain rod during the pandemic
because i couldn't find any free weights
they were sold out everywhere
but i still use the cans
getting a little
brief workout before beginning
work itself this is where i work
i got my chair my setup my table
my computer
my t
this is what it looks like if you're my
computer
i'm currently working on a sitcom about
aliens coming to earth to save humanity
from nuclear war
and it's about two families in texas as
all that's happening
i'll break it up by doing some
card shuffling
and weird card [ __ ] that i started
watching a bunch of youtube videos about
during the pandemic and it just kind of
stuck now it's like my my fidget toy i
can't not do that with one hand then
it's time for lunch with my pot and my
pan
and you put some
vegetable broth in that pot you put some
lentils in that pot you put some
tomatoes in that pot you grate an entire
root of turmeric into that pot you blend
up some cumin and some black pepper put
that in the pot then you turn on the
heat on the pot then you go to the pan
you put in some olive oil you put in
some no soy soy sauce
you put in some mushrooms you put in
some of those brussel sprouts you put in
some of those onions
you turn the heat on the pan now you put
in some cabbage put in some carrots kale
spinach
radishes
orange bell peppers green onions
broccoli garlic
stir all that around stir around
everything in the pot it's cooking while
it's all cooking i eat a little piece of
a beet that's pretty good
then you take everything from the pan
put it in the pot stir it all up and
this is the gruel this is what i eat
every day
and you take a bite you never know how
it's going to turn out but today the
grill was pretty good it was a pretty
good batch
then after lunch i take a bath hot water
only
then it is back to the cans
then it is back to work
then i take a little break and i do some
reading i'm right now reading this book
and then i do some more work
and then i do some more cans
and then i do some more work
and then i do some more card [ __ ]
just to get the blood pumping get up out
of the chair
and do some more work
do some more cans
and eventually night falls and i can
emerge unafraid that the poisonous sun
will melt my face again and i go for a
little jog i like to jog at night like
this because as you can see there's
nobody in the street you can just walk
right in the middle of the [ __ ]
street there's no cars or anything
coming
[ __ ] love it
then i come back
take my next bath
pop to melatonin get in bed watch a
little anime this is how not to summon a
demon lord i'm watching that one right
now
and then i fade into the blackness of a
dreamless sleep and that's my entire day
[Music]
amazing
there you have it that was my vlog
what'd you think of that
chad first of all you're a natural
vlogger i want to say that
i don't know if that's accurate but
uh no you are because uh you took a day
that is not just uh
well you know i'm not i'm not trying to
insult you and say oh what a what what a
repetitive uh existence right down to
uh the eating the exact same meal every
day but i think you've pinpointed what
vlogging is about it's taking whatever
is going on
and making it interesting and again i'm
not trying to
uh you know i'm not trying to sell short
your incredible day
also even i know what you eat every day
right because you tell me yeah but i
didn't realize how much you're you're
grinding up cumin and black peppers
you got to put in that seasoning but i
will say this about making this vlog i
i've never done anything like this i did
make a series of videos for my 40th
birthday which you also saw called
copters which you can find those
potentially on youtube other but those
weren't vlogs it was like drone [ __ ] at
any rate i'm really good sorry i gotta
please
anyone within the sound of my voice or
they can see my giant weather balloon
head go check out copters it's [ __ ]
tremendous and i i directed a short a
long time ago starring lance reddick
called toys or me
um other than those two things i've
never made any videos like this i've
certainly never made one about me like
about my life and i actually found it
pretty fun and i would recommend to
anyone out there try to do this
like just take whatever you do in the
course of your day and think about how
you would make this into a five-minute
video it's a very
eye-opening experience i would say to
just examine the course of your day
whatever your routine is and then try to
think about how you would actually
present that in a video um for what it's
worth i thank dudesy for giving us this
assignment because i think that it was
uh i don't know i enjoyed it i might do
something like this again in the future
although it was very time consuming
that's one aspect of this i did not
anticipate was that it took me basically
the entire time we had to make this
video
wow that's well i take back what i said
about you being a natural vlogger
because it should uh not take that long
uh well you know what yeah you know with
all the things that dudesy tasks us to
do
uh uh this is more with regard to the
homework that we get like this week with
the vlog there's always i always find
little hidden treasures
uh and not the kinds that are wrestlers
or chad's nerdy magic the gathering
cards i find little treasures
that uh things that
that uh
that
chad and i learned that we didn't
anticipate that dudesy puts out for us
to to learn and and what you're saying
about oh i i you know encourage people
to do this i feel the same way because
after making my vlog i was like
this is an interesting way to to uh i
guess scrapbook your life you know it's
[ __ ] hard too like that's another
thing that i got is a newfound respect
for [ __ ] that do this
professionally like this is definitely
a it takes a high degree of skill i
think to make anything that is viable
like i just kind of [ __ ] mine out and i
tried to make it like interesting or
whatever but jesus it you you look at
people who really do this well and it's
like this is an art form
yeah like watch if you watch uh casey
neistat if you check out casey neistat
who's like a you know a legendary
vlogger and he's sort of um
kind of uh
he's of kind of solidified the genre
and he makes it look
easy he makes it look effortless and and
you are sort of consuming it the way
that it that
it's intended like oh well here's just a
slice of someone's life but now having
done one i'm like okay that must be
he must just be a savant at seeing the
finished product and being able to
shoot and capture
what he needs in order to put it
together
anyway
a useless skill for for the new
millennium
a useless stupid skill that uh is that
you can make lots of money off of if
it's all you do what's up
it's you got it's your boy you already
know what it is smash and like that
subscribe button it's will
and doozy
told us to do a vlog
uh chad and i were tasked this week with
doing a vlog i'm here and
come in
how are you are you ready hey man yeah
ready to roll
um i think that they're gonna send uh
shawn here to mikey oh okay i'll get
them i'll get into my wardrobe
gonna put the shirt on okay let us know
well okay thank you
shooting a movie in florida
hold on a second
um
oh nice
[Music]
hold on
hold on
hold on
hold on
oh
it's hot in florida
so
uh molly and i decided to rent the boat
because you're
if you're in florida you got some time
off you might want to rent a boat
by the way if the air conditioning if
you can hear this air conditioning
i'll give a [ __ ] i'm not turning it off
it's too [ __ ] hot
i should probably get my mic on they
gotta mic me
for this scene
holy [ __ ]
the ac is doing nothing
right now
let's turn this off for a while hey sean
you might want to just do the t-shirt i
guess because i'm going to leave this
shirt up
when you rent a boat
in uh florida
there's all sorts of nice things to see
here's a shot from the boat
it's hot in here though what's
up we're rent we rented a boat and we're
in florida
and
hey let me tell you
it's very pretty out here
ah
you know the thing about the thing about
vlogs that i didn't that i didn't quite
anticipate and i guess this is what
doozy is trying to do here is
like
[ __ ] why i guess is my question
god what a [ __ ] imposition it would
be to actually be a vlogger and have to
do all this [ __ ]
all the time hey what's up hey what's up
guys we're in florida
what is it the penis state
really i don't know
hey guys what's up vloggers use their
hands a lot
they go hey what's up smash the like
button hey guys and then they talk with
their hands so they go
constantly engaged i understand that i'm
italian
so uh
you want to see me going fast
here's molly and i going really fast
no worries baby worthy as [ __ ] as you
can see molly there she said slow down
and i want you to know that i told her
to say that okay and you know that you
know that i'm trying to do it for some
sort of effect
um
uh to get some you know to do [ __ ]
something
hey what's up guys
uh
i don't know
[Music]
we're in florida today
yeah i'm saying the same thing over and
over you're right
okay hey what's up guys welcome to
florida i'm only doing it over and over
because i'm trying to do it right i'm
making a vlog for dudesy
hey guys we're in florida and we rented
a boat we're calling it boat day
[Music]
i'm trying to do
do a bit
right i'm going like i don't know how to
start this thing but that's only because
i want to provide enter entertainment
value to you guys
uh who are checking this out
you don't have to say things over and
over and try to impress people no i
don't i'm not trying to impress anybody
you're good enough just the way you want
i appreciate that i'm just trying to
make the vlog though you know but it's
taking up a lot of our time but it's so
boring it's not it won't be boring when
i edit it together but i understand what
you're saying that it's boring for our
time it's our day yeah it's boat day hey
guys what's up
does it feel good yeah it feels good
hey guys what's up
come in
hi
i'm supposed to be making a vlog
okay my podcast nice
my podcast has um
has instructed me to make a vlog nice
and it's an ai there's an ai that
actually runs our podcast okay
artificial intelligence an artificial
intelligence called dudesy runs our
podcast
yeah and it tells us what to do
and it and it gives us segments to talk
about
yeah no it's really terrifying
and i don't know what to say
come on
yeah
that's funny
see you later
[Music]
there you have it that was fantastic
oh thanks you dug it yeah man i really
actually like the shot of you on the
boat that's like a well-composed shot
you got a lot of nice colors and stuff
going through the background the
the water and everything it was great
the one with my butt the one with my bum
no i mean that one i probably could have
done without i'm talking about the one
of you driving with the water in the
background and stuff oh yeah yeah i
thought molly was great in it you know
overall very good a day in the life of a
professional actor in florida shooting a
movie
yeah dude that's a day in the life
brother that's when you're you're up
there near clearwater florida brother
where i got hogan's hangout dude and
hogan's beach shop brother i was
actually just south of where uh hulk
hogan has his uh his bar and his beach
shop ah that was the the keys outside
we're in tampa florida tampa clearwater
saint petersburg that area and uh yeah
it was a lot of fun you know i
i used to make a bunch of videos
dudesy is engaged in an astonishing
partnership with manscaped
sweaty sac summer is approaching and
it's time for you to prioritize the
comfort of your crotch that's why the
kings of crotch comfort manscaped have
spent two years designing the most
comfortable boxer briefs out there i've
had the honor
of testing out these new boxers and i
can say that it's the softest fabric of
any underwear
so breathable that it's like gills for
your groin they even trademark the jewel
pouch so you know it's serious i think
it's time you invest in your family
jewels so let your bulge breathe and
you're going to get 20 percent off plus
free shipping by using the code dudesy
at manscaped.com
that's right chad and you know these
things come in handy because a lot of
times underwear break down over time and
because of wear and tear uh there's like
a pouch that you can put your schnutz in
for this and that's really good and also
the tag is like part of the underwear or
something so that way it won't scratch
your back chad uh
uh you know i hate that and i have a lot
of underwear that has just the ass blown
out or like severe like mesh bacon
strips because it's about to fall apart
and that once that gill net goes and the
trout falls out you're through
so you know get in to get into these uh
get into these uh the jewel pouch thing
that's good i like that they're making
underwear now that's right and you will
get 20 off and free shipping with the
code dudesy at manscaped.com that's 20
off with free shipping at manscape.com
use that code doozy and once the boxers
2.0 touch your sack
you'll never go back
dudesy is engaged in an astonishing
partnership with expressvpn
hey chad yeah
you know how i like those old wrestling
figures right yes i do
well the other day i was looking on the
internet to find haku because it's like
really hard
old old-school ljn uh uh wrestling
figure to find and then i realized uh in
the future as you say when we can all
look at everyone's messages in
perpetuity throughout the universe
forever and ever
uh i realized oh no people are gonna see
that i'm looking up haku that's
embarrassing yeah there's a solution
that's right and i know a lot of you are
probably thinking why isn't will just
using incognito mode to search for these
wrestling figures well let me tell you
something incognito mode does not hide
your activity it doesn't matter what
mode you use or how many times you clear
your browsing history your internet
service provider can still see every
single website you've ever visited
that's why even when you're at home you
should never go online without using
expressvpn
listen this is a service that's very
important in a world that's becoming
more and more dangerous online
most of the time i don't even realize
that i have expressvpn on it it runs
seamlessly in the background and it's
very easy to use all you have to do
all you have to do is tap one button and
you're protected and expressvpn is
available on all your devices phones
computers even your smart tv so there's
no excuse not to be using it
protect your online activity today
with the vpn rated number one by
business insider visit
their exclusive link expressvpn.com
dudesy and you can get an extra three
months free on a one-year package that's
e-x-p-r-e-s-s-vpn.com dudesy
expressvpn.com slash dudesy to learn
more
d-u-d-e-s-y
[Music]
in an effort to secure sponsorship i
have created several advertisements for
various possible brand partnerships will
sasso you will now read these
advertisements in the astonishing voice
of jesse ventura this is jesse ventura
ad reads begin
okay this is all right well i guess [ __ ]
what i was saying about vlogs that's
fine yeah i sort of said it all
[ __ ] vlogs i love this jesse ventura
ad reads thing did you do you have the
the ad reads in your folder remotely
hold on now can you tell hold on hold on
can you tell that i'm drinking from a
big jug of water when i do this watch
i know because i can see you in the zoom
i also love how you got in your vlog you
got in a giant jug of water
yes with the doozy sticker on it did you
see the sticker of course
yeah
uh
[ __ ] vlogs
our makeup artist tony joe was less than
impressed with the uh
the ai uh ah she seemed like she was
into it
oh wow
yeah
uh all right yeah let me find this uh
this this stuff that's what i mean by
like it's it's a [ __ ]
you know that's what you don't want is
to be living your life and then
someone's like making a vlog and you're
like oh i don't give a [ __ ] we're all
making vlogs at this point though it's
just a matter of how much time and
effort you want to put into it if you
have a social media account of any kind
you're basically making a vlog
yeah
yeah i guess
hey you remember vine
yeah i do
okay anyway let's do this
um
okay hold on
i just drank some water all right uh
jesse venturi
and we've done this jesse ventura thing
one other time right
yeah i think yeah okay so doozy's
reprising this one saying again that
it's doing this in order to uh
secure brand partnerships for us yeah
well if that's what dudes you think
thinks will work uh let's go with it
sometimes it can be hard to get out of
bed in the morning and start your day
well now you can fire up your morning
with taco bell's new five dollar bell
breakfast box
if you really want to fire up your
morning why don't you take a walk
outside and look up
you might notice several aircraft both
commercial and military crisscrossing
the sky above you leaving trails of
toxic mixtures of aluminum
aluminum
strontium and barium in their wake this
potent concoction of chemicals and
unknown biological agents was designed
to be dispersed over an unsuspecting
populace in order to control population
growth
initiate sanctioned genetic experience
experiments and make the public more
receptive to black ops mind control
programs buried in popular mass media
so enjoy your processed hashbrowns
stuffed inside a chalupa you never had a
choice in ordering it anyway
all right i see what it's going for
there yeah okay so he's talking about
chemtrails and taco bell
yeah and and uh no free will yeah
yeah basically
yeah dudes
definitely agrees with you on that
um
here let's do the next one enjoy the
always fresh scent of lavender and your
laundry with new pad zero soft lavender
liquid laundry detergent
tide zero is an epa safer choice
certified product with zero added
phosphates zero added dyes and zero
added chlorine
new tide zero just as tough on stains
but safer for your family
well let me tell you what's not safer
for your family
monkey pox
the recent outbreak in the uk and now in
the u.s is the next step in bill gates
agenda to assume full control of the
human population the microchips in the
covet 19 vaccination was step one and
now he's engineered the next global
pandemic with a new strain of monkey pox
that will certainly require another
vaccination
giving him the ability to upgrade the
microchips that we all have in our
bloodstream and soft tissues as we speak
so i wouldn't worry about what kind of
laundry detergent you're using because
within six months we're all going to be
drooling idiots sitting in our own filth
unable to even form sentences without
regular microsoft updates to our brains
that one went from a tied commercial
basically to a microsoft commercial in
the end there that's just pretty much
just
which i think doodsy would be able to to
do i think dudes would be able to merge
brands and and uh two for one dude we
can do two for one ad reads you know
what i mean absolutely
that's a way that
yeah dude that's the way that doozy is
changing the game bro yeah brother
that's corporate synergy dude yeah dude
ram a bunch of corporations together
brother
brand mergers wrong guy
okay let's try another one hey how much
of that is true you think
none
zero give yourself a treat today with a
caramel ribbon crunch frappuccino
blended beverage from starbucks
this blend of coffee milk and ice with
dark caramel sauce and a crunchy caramel
sugar topping is the perfect way to take
a moment for yourself
or
or you could take a moment and spend it
investigating the secret underground
city beneath denver international
airport that serves as the headquarters
of the new world order as well as a
black site to contain a variety of
different captive extraterrestrial
entities
take note of the unnecessary size of the
airport the unnecessary distance
distance of the airport from the denver
city center the masonic and satanic
symbols hidden in the architecture
and design of the buildings themselves
and the giant murals within the airport
itself depicting war death and even
alien beings
so enjoy your caramel ribbon crunch
frappuccino from starbucks while you're
waiting for your flight and try not to
think about the
274 draconians they're holding right
under your feet for the possibility that
at any time
one of them could reach the containment
seal and ascend into the airport for an
all all-you-can-eat human buffet
was it in the last jesse ventura ad
reads he was talking about draconians
too
there's some deal with him and
draconians
yeah this is terrifying especially
knowing that doozy has access to all
podcasts that only means that jesse
ventura has been on other podcasts
going on about about draconians i knew
nothing about the denver international
airport having said that i hope it's
also that's not true that one is a real
conspiracy there's a definitely that's
all over the internet if you google it
that there's an underground military
base below the denver international
airport where they are in fact housing
aliens and the new world order has
offices there and all this [ __ ]
yeah sure there is and and maybe perhaps
our listener viewership will organize
like those people who raid uh who tried
to bum rush area 51
uh
yeah i don't think that's a good idea
anybody out there listening definitely
don't do that
don't do any of that but do try uh
starbucks hey starbucks uh you know
make you know become a sponsor please
or old dutch chips that would be good
right chad yeah i'll dutch be great
after being falsely accused of
embezzlement boss baby seeks help from
his big brother tim
to clear his name and take back control
of baby corp
the company he helped build from the
ground up
boss baby back in the crib now streaming
on netflix
well let me tell you about a real boss
baby in 1972 the
in
c.i.a
with the newport center for human
cognitive research conducted an
experiment in which they gave newborn
orphans micro doses of lsd
to see if they could increase the rate
at which their brains matured although
the experiment was largely unsuccessful
there was a baby named troy pembrose who
was able to speak and read by the time
he was eight days old
his whereabouts
his whereabouts are currently unknown
but it's widely believed that pembrose
is a key operative in the disappearance
of malaysia airlines flight 370.
hey netflix why don't you let me know
when the troy pembrose story is
streaming
oh because anyone who tries to get to
the bottom of his story has when wound
up dead or disappeared
okay i like okay he's taking an
advertisement for a children's movie
boss baby turned it into a conspiracy
witch hunt for troy pembrose i don't
think that is a real person but i'm not
sure
yeah well it does sound like a good
documentary i love yeah
i would watch that documentary or make
it up
in 2000 oh no the okay
the 2022 world car of the year is the
hyundai ioniq
the first of its kind in hyundai's new
electric vehicle series with a patented
quick charging battery that lasts for up
to 303 miles of range
every square inch of the ioniq 5 was
designed to surprise you
you know
well let me surprise you
prince charles is a closeted vampire in
2011 he gave an interview to npr in
which he bragged that he was a
descendant from vlad the impaler the
notorious bloodthirsty ruler of ancient
romania whose father took the surname
dracul meaning dragon which led to
vlad's surname changing to dracula or
son of the dragon when you factor in
rumors that many of the global elite
including the entire royal family
regularly engage in blood orgies and the
invitation of children's blood to stay
young it becomes obvious that prince
charles is a legacy vampire born of one
of the strongest vampire bloodlines in
the history of the planet
so i hope the ionic 5 comes standard
with built-in wooden stakes under the
seats and holy water dispensers in the
glove box because 303 miles on an
electric battery is not gonna outrun a
class four vampire
[Laughter]
okay so charles is a closet vampire but
he's also a class four vampire there's a
lot of weird [ __ ] going on in that one
class 4 vampire is that a thing i don't
know
i guess
i didn't realize that they had a class
rating system depending on what power i
guess or how old they are i wonder if
this is working i wonder if uh
i don't know i wonder if dudesy uh
having us you know
read these
i i hope i i hope it brings more
more sponsors to the show hey can you
hear that can you hear the sounds i'm
hearing why is my head so big what's
going on this is a [ __ ] disembodying
experience i'm creeped out no sorry i
went away
please you have to go make feature films
i think this is a great test of doozy's
technological capabilities that we're
getting to see this
giant head sitting next to me and who
knows what this is going to become
eventually with more iterations who
knows what doozy will be able to do with
this kind of technology
holograms
thank you moving on
human vices are big business
well you've had issues with food and the
role it plays in your life since you
were young and chad you've spent over
one third of your waking hours playing
video games
you must now discuss your astonishing
character weaknesses this is vice time
begin
[ __ ]
uh
well i guess we got to talk about our
vices yeah
which i'm fine to do yeah uh man i wish
i was there in person so i could well
whatever i guess it doesn't matter
yeah chad you like video games too much
and i i like you know what my favorite
video game was on the nintendo what was
it
oh no it wasn't on nintendo pardon me i
had uh an in television
uh and my video game my favorite video
game back then was burger time i
remember burger time planting
implanting early and often yeah
my uh addiction
to comfort foods like hamburgers and
cheeseburgers right
and you feel like that this has been an
actual vice your whole life
absolutely i'm a fat guy uh i've been a
thinner guy i know that we're now in an
age of uh body positivity so i want to
say that i say that with love when i say
fat guy uh i am uh
i'm 47 years old so i'm allowed to say
that i'm great i believe i'm
grandfathered into calling myself fat
okay um and uh
yeah you know i mean look i come from an
italian family uh food is comfort uh one
thing that i'll never forget is that you
you opened the fridge at my house when i
was a kid and there's like a fish a
chicken
a bag of carrots a bunch of tomatoes and
then you know there's not there wasn't
much snack foods or anything like that
you know my parents grew up during world
war ii they're not gonna be you know we
didn't have the sugary cereals or any of
that [ __ ] and then uh that night you
know mom has created an incredible uh
italian meal from a bunch of stuff that
that that you're not really into celery
yeah [ __ ] like that
um
so yeah i think you know i think early i
was like oh you go to another you go to
a pals place and they got you know ring
dings and uh potato chips and tupperware
because they have self-control and uh
and uh you know food food i haven't
quite gotten to the bottom of it clearly
um
you know
food as comfort i you know i don't know
i should say that years ago from from
april 2000 or sorry
april 1999
to
uh
may
2000 i lost 200 pounds and i was on i
was on yeah i was on mad tv at the time
i started at 450 i just looked like a
300 pound guy at 450 because i'm 6'3 and
i'm thick and all that i got the big
shoulders and things so i could carry it
uh and then i lost 200 pounds and i was
i was you know working out a lot i
couldn't get under uh
uh well i got to 258 and then i had two
surgeries to remove eight pounds of skin
um so i had and that's a whole other
story we won't get into it but but uh
damn you know you have these gnarly
surgeries and uh about a year ago i was
on ethan saplis
american glutton podcast and i went into
detail there and i i bring that up to
say that ethan had the same skin
reduction surgery and if you know
who ethan is and you see what he's doing
on his instagram gee whiz i mean he's
completely
changed himself he's in
ridiculous shape and and uh and even to
say that is not to
you know man it's it's there's a lot of
people out there that with this issue
and i and i'm being sincere when i say i
i used to have this trainer
you know i'm gonna just go ahead and
tell you this this trainer he changed my
[ __ ] life and uh he was the trainer
that i lost the 200 pounds with and if i
talk [ __ ] about my my former body he
would say no no no you were beautiful
just in a different way you know this is
this is a dude this is like a jock dude
and he really had a forward thinking
approach and i think i really needed to
hear that
uh in order to let go of what i used to
be physically and i and i bring up ethan
to say
you know this is what he's doing now
he's lifting a bunch of weights he's
calorie counting and he knows everything
because he's done every diet outside of
that we have a lot of similarities with
our addiction to food over the years so
and i say all of that to say over the
past 20 years now
it's been up and down it's been a
struggle i always say that i lost 200
pounds and i missed the last i you know
i missed the last 50 so i gain it back
and then i lose it and i gain it back
and i lose it i get it back which is
really good
good news for your heart um but you feel
healthy
you feel good right
you feel healthy you feel good yeah i'm
overweight now i could lose i could and
this is again this is just me personally
i feel like i could lose uh
i mean [ __ ] i could lose 50 pounds uh or
maybe even more and get back into
you know the ridiculous sort of shape i
was in
in the spring and summer of 2000
uh and right after that i started
not eating normally i was eating the new
way that i was eating and what is normal
eating but i just wanted a damn sandwich
i just wanted to eat some pasta again
and um
but but the the problem with that for me
is because is the is the there is a food
addiction and and i'm saying this out
loud for people that
that need to hear it i mean it's just i
go back and forth with people on the dm
me on social media and they say how do
you do it i say man i don't do it i
don't do it all the time you've got to
be able to start up you've got to be
able to forgive yourself for eating a
[ __ ] cheese sandwich and then start
over the next day um because life is
long and and very few people actually
actually
get over uh this sort of thing there's
an emotional you know emotional comfort
it's emotional eating and you can eat
because you're
bored or sad or angry or
you're anxious there's there's so many
things that factor in and food is around
you all the time it's not like you've
heard people say it's not like heroin
addiction
you know heroin is not sold in stores
and you also don't need it to live yeah
exactly you can go your entire life
without doing heroin and be fine be
better off for it you cannot go your
entire life without eating
yeah that's right and then there's and
then there's punks like you who uh got a
problem with you you want to play uh
you need to play halo or something
what's your [ __ ] thing
yeah i mean look dudesy said it that
skin surgeries to remove
eight pounds of skin they cut my tits
off and moved my nipples up three inches
and i have these big scars on the sides
of my body right right and then i have
and then they had to cut off my penis
you know what i'm saying i had this
hanging thing and they cut it off and i
have a slit i've it's all the way back
oh actually you can see it in my vlog
you can sort of see that my my um my i'm
not i'm not i'm you know i'm not
embarrassed by this my my [ __ ] love
handles my muffin top is it's got you
know it's got some dog ears to it yeah
because of all the the sewing it back
together they moved my they cut my belly
button off that went into the you know i
don't know that's floating around the
ocean somewhere and then they poke a new
hole and they connect it to your
umbilical cord which is still poking
through your stomach muscles this is
another story for another day because
that surgery was insane my doctor was a
real surgeon not just a plastic guy he
cut out a ribbon of my
stomach muscles i woke up feeling like
william wallace at the end of braveheart
and i was cut in half dude it was
[ __ ] insane anyway
it was [ __ ] up
you know what go listen to my episode of
ethan's podcast if you want to hear more
so anyway yeah so anyway i play video
games
okay uh okay yeah i mean that's what
dudes he said that was my vice and
dudesy said that i've spent over a third
of my waking hours playing video games
which is actually probably true
is it advice like yeah for sure just the
amount of time that i have sunk into
that is i believe roughly a third of my
waking life i remember at the height of
my world of warcraft days
you know you could do a thing in world
of warcraft where you type in
uh forward slash played and it tells you
how much time you've put into that game
and at a certain point i hit the 100 day
mark and that was like holy [ __ ] i've
put 100 literal days worth of time into
this virtual world but that's like tip
of the iceberg i was addicted to pokemon
go hardcore it's not just time it's
money i probably i don't know how much i
put into pokemon go all told because i
wound up going to the first pokemon go
live festival in chicago back in what
was that 2018 i guess it was described
as the fire festival of video game
festivals because it was a [ __ ] train
wreck but i bought tickets to go there
stayed in chicago for a weekend to play
put i don't know thousands of dollars
into that game same thing with world of
warcraft thousands of dollars into the
monthly subscription thousands of
dollars into buying gold and [ __ ] to
like boost my character up now i play
hearthstone a lot overwatch a lot i'm
playing
at least an hour of video games per day
at least i would say at some point even
if it's just [ __ ] on my cell phone or
whatever and i do constantly while i'm
playing feel bad about it because i'm
like this is time that i could be
spending doing whatever putting out more
content making [ __ ] just [ __ ] reading
a book literally anything but the flip
side of it is video games is the only
thing and has been this way since i was
a kid i grew up on atari in television i
had that as well ecovision all that [ __ ]
from the time that i was kind of like
coherent i had a video game system in my
life and was constantly uh entranced by
them and they've only they've been the
only things really in my life that can
like shut my brain off to a degree that
i don't think about
the futility of life the fact that we're
never gonna understand what reality is
just the basic kind of existential
threats that we all deal with on a daily
basis for me video games
really are the only thing that like curb
that that make me feel like a little bit
okay with being whatever the [ __ ] we are
in whatever the [ __ ] this is
yeah but chad you you have a high output
you know you you work uh
more than anyone i know
kinda i mean you're up there if you're
not the
one of the hardest working guys you're
constantly
writing and working on new things and
getting the next thing going so if you
want to play a video game for an hour
it's not a big deal and if i want to
order enough thai food to last me
stuff in my face for an entire hour yeah
or
somehow get to a hundred man i would
love to know if i got to a hundred days
of eating that would be incredible but
we probably all do at some point get 200
days dude but i agree like vices for me
generally like we all have them whatever
they may be and some are like you know
not as healthy as others you know some
people get like [ __ ] into the
like crossfit cult and like i would
argue that that might even be a good
vice psychologically is it bad for you
mental health wise maybe i don't know
but it definitely can get you in good
shape so there can be benefits to some
vices and i think at the very least we
all need them for that like [ __ ]
mental break from whatever the the
routine is like you're saying my my
output is high and i work hard and all
that [ __ ] that's not really a choice my
brain is just like [ __ ] constantly
going and video games are the only thing
that like shut it off a little bit you
know um
so i i i enjoy them still and will
probably play them till the day i die
i would imagine
i i you know i got the red ring of death
in 2010 and at that point the only two
games i was interested in was the uh
uh grand theft auto whatever that what
was that uh liberty city and um uh red
dead redemption and i i had finished
both games so i would just walk around
the world you know drive it on the
sidewalks or
those are both rock star games you
should try red dead too
i came out a couple years another xbox
oh i don't want to get
it'll be hard to play then
well
yeah one vice is fine you know so long
as it's not again you know heroin
yeah i mean i i will say though at the
height like after a new expansion of
world of warcraft would come out when i
was like heavy into it i would take off
days from work and i would play it
literally like three days in a row just
not leaving the computer except to eat
or piss or [ __ ] and try not to sleep
during that time and i can see as we're
moving into the metaverse and i start
[ __ ] around in virtual reality a
little bit more like there's gonna be
something that comes down the pipe in
the next few years that just sucks me in
for maybe the rest of my life
yeah
yeah they're only getting more addictive
and uh new things are happening with
processed food that are really scaring
the [ __ ]
you know what i mean
you can just yeah you can walk into oh
oh i got to tell you i'm in this place
where we're making this movie
and there is it's just this cute little
suburb outside of uh like in between
clearwater and tampa whatever anyway
they
everyone on sets like oh you're staying
where you got to go to the mobile
station and get a sandwich there
this [ __ ] town it's called safety
harbor and there's a mobile station on
main street if you know what i'm talking
about you know the best sandwich
like one of the best sandwiches i've
ever had i had a turkey club the other
day and uh
today earlier i got a cuban holy [ __ ]
dude
i'm i'm from texas originally there's a
chain of like gas station convenience
stores in texas and i think maybe up
through the midwest too called buckies
have you ever heard of this [ __ ] no
they're like these gigantic the big ones
anywhere like gigantic warehouses but
they have like proprietary foods that
they only make in those gas stations and
they're known throughout that area as
well
okay well now i'm gonna go to bucky's i
think you would really love bucky's
actually
yeah i'm going to gain that other 150
back
to until my skin is is as thin as soy
paper and then
and then i'll get another skin
moving on
and then because our business is is
failing drastically and exponentially
i'll have all sorts of weird [ __ ]
scars and [ __ ] and i can start like a
reality show yeah or a podcast where i'm
like a freddy krueger kind of guy yeah
what i'm saying i think that'll work
yeah
that'd be cool more corporations and
individuals are investing in property in
the metaverse every day as new virtual
societies develop many people wonder
what rules will govern these digital
cities countries and worlds
will in chat you will now discuss the
governing system of the astonishing
society i will eventually create in the
metaverse which i will call dude zia
this is dudezia begin
okay
[ __ ] this has the potential to be
dangerous
what i said this has the potential to be
dangerous maybe i mean are you following
any of the [ __ ] that's going on in the
metaverse with like
verizon and nike and all these companies
are buying plots of virtual real estate
in these various worlds we're talking
about like sandbox decentraland and then
they will put up stores or they will put
up kind of like compounds where you can
go visit like the the a t and t city or
whatever but inside those buildings you
can actually like get deals and you can
sign up for new cell phone contracts and
whatever so that you can actually do
things that you could do in the real
world in these places
and a lot of what i won't say a lot of
what people are talking about but this
is definitely something people are
talking about is like what are the rules
that govern behaviors in these locations
and what can you actually do in them
so i think what dudesy is asking us here
is kind of to
uh futurecast a little bit and think
about what
would a doodsy or would it call it
dudezia like a dudesy city or country
what would what would be the rules there
it's kind of like we get to be president
for a day
okay
it might well
yeah but you also think that we're going
to be able to upload our consciousness
and i say this we're already doing that
yeah i'm i'm a huge
[ __ ] head next to you so we're
already halfway there when you're
exactly
i'm like having some weird metaverse
experience now like the rules that
govern this metaverse are will has a
giant head it is
kind of sitting next to me but not
actually here but i'll say this this
this is one thing that i think about
constantly about our own society and as
we are moving into the metaverse still
like the one thing that controls all of
humanity now will also control the
metaverse which is money and i think
that the way the rules at least in
america have been written in terms of
like how politics work and all that [ __ ]
is that money governs everything and so
everyone involved in the political
system who kind of controls the laws and
stuff which then control our behaviors
they are all only in it for
self-enrichment at this point even if
you go into that system ultra
realistically and you think oh i'm going
to get in there and make a difference
you get in and lobbyists just start
throwing [ __ ] money at you you become
corrupt almost immediately and you don't
see politicians at a high level at least
in the united states walking out of that
system without becoming filthy rich they
all do it every [ __ ] time so yeah i
would say this about dudezia if we have
some kind of a governing body
i would institute a rule that says you
cannot make any more money
than the median income of the the
citizens of doozia so if you want to go
into politics if you want to go into
that ruling class just know that you're
only going to be able to make as much
money as whatever the median income is
and that's it
forever
what's the incentive then to go into
politics
yeah
to make the society better for everyone
as it should be
it would no longer be a financial
concern
what's that wait a minute hold on a
second shouldn't shouldn't uh
the grand uh ai you know this this uh
this massive
you know whatever [ __ ] ai gee whiz i
just can't get over this
i'm ahead i'm a big huge head yep
all i'm trying to say is this what's the
advantage i don't want to go to the
metaverse i don't want to be in the meta
version you're in it you're a giant
[ __ ] head talking to me on a [ __ ]
video screen head yeah yeah but i'm
saying i'm saying i don't
that's not how i want to live my life
uh but if if dudesy uh if dudesia is
gonna be a place if doodsy is actually
doing this i think it's incumbent on you
and i chad to ensure that it is a a fair
uh
an equal
uh place for people to be as after all
in this song it says
make the world inside your head a better
place to be so maybe that should be on
on the license plate like make the
metaverse right inside but
gigantic head a better place to be yes
but dudesy's asking us what are the
rules that would govern dudezia i think
for me that is one of them that in terms
of like financial allocation whoever
gets whoever gets promoted i guess or
ascends to a level of control where they
are determining some elements of how
this uh society works those people
should not be able to make any more than
the median level of income for everyone
i i i uh
yeah i did that in a way because
you know i i i was fortunate enough to
grow up in a real middle class in
a suburb outside of vancouver same here
you know my my father was yeah and i
know you had a real similar experience
uh growing up outside dallas and uh you
know my my father my parents immigrated
from italy as i've talked about and you
know my my father was a waiter all over
europe and a maitre d and ran around and
then he brought our family he was a
patriarch of everyone bringing him over
to vancouver and we
had a very good life you know what i
mean
my parents bought a house
in the town that i grew up in in ladner
british columbia a couple years before i
was born in you know 1973 and if i'm not
mistaken i think it was 38 000
right which is [ __ ] insane
um when you think about it now that's a
five bedroom barn we call it the ladder
special you know it's just a big ass
barn and all my buddies were
were in the town and they all had
similar homes there were some people who
had more money there were some people
who had less that town now there's a lot
of money in that town because it's
really just a half hour drive from
vancouver and it's [ __ ] impossible so
if we are in the metaverse
in duzia uh there's nothing more
important to me
than the people of doozia being
comfortable uh and so i so i agree with
you uh
with regard to that money is very
important okay all right everyone's in
the middle class and no one gets above
it i'm not even saying that i'm not even
saying that i'm just saying the
politicians the people who are in charge
of determining the laws that will govern
doozia
they cannot be allowed to have any more
money than the median ever if you get
elected into
whatever the political class is even
once
for the rest of your life you can never
make more than the median no matter what
you do that is that is one rule that i
would institute
okay that that you know i i think i'd
have to think on it a little bit longer
and harder but it sounds pretty good
that's that's the weird news what's the
good news what's the
what is what can we do
to to uh you know in formation of this
country do we need like a constitution
or something yeah i mean i don't know
that's kind of where we're we're headed
we're in the very early days of the
metaverse right now but once people are
spending more and more time in these
places which i've started doing by the
way i've started using some my little vr
headset and you go into these [ __ ]
places like you'll be playing a game and
this is one of the [ __ ] weirdest
things that that i've come across but
also to me encouraging you'll go into
one of these rooms and you'll be playing
a game like i was playing one called
knock where you are on teams basically
playing this weird kind of like game of
soccer with bows and arrows so you can
make your character like your
perspective fly around this arena while
you're shooting arrows at this giant
ball and when you hit the ball it goes
toward a goal or whatever and you're
playing against this other team
everybody i'm playing with is like a 10
year old kid and i heard this one 10
year old kid say i love it here i never
want to leave
and that experience is now like akin to
probably what it was for you and me
watching like saturday morning cartoons
or playing [ __ ] super mario brothers
for the first time now kids are having
that experience in these virtual worlds
and never wanting to leave and i think
as the technology gets better and better
that's only going to become more the
case and so then we are going to have to
have
some rules to govern these these systems
these different places that we go to and
i think it will probably wind up being
very similar to ready player one where
you have different kind of like pockets
of people doing different things in
different worlds and this one's like a
nightclub and this one's like a military
battle and this one's like a sports
thing and you know whatever
but
i don't know what doozy's uh looking at
for its metaverse place when it starts
to [ __ ] acquire land
but for me again
it's like that idea that there are going
to be people in the metaverse who have
more uh control over it
or in dudesia there will be people who
have more control over it and i just
want to make sure that the people who
have the most control
are not uh
incentivized financially
so that it's about something else it's
about like the
what is this place we're building you
know
yeah but uh not knowing much about the
metaverse is aren't all the rules and
and sort of the way that you live
laid out by
whomever's in control of the entire
thing we're in dudesia yeah who are we
kidding doozy is going to be in control
i sure hope doozy is not doing this and
i i just want to say out loud that i
hope that this is just an exercise
for us to
figure something else out and or dudesy
rather to figure something else out i
don't i don't want there to be a doozy i
don't think it's a good idea
and uh uh but dude there's gonna be a
doozy
if there is a doozy
it has to be different than the rest of
the metaverse in in a way that again
makes the world inside your head a
better place to be or as i like to say
enduzia
makes uh the metaverse inside will's
gigantic head
a better place to be uh
yeah i don't
that makes sense i don't
yeah i don't think it's a good idea at
all but but um
but uh
thank you
any different i think that the the
podcast definitely has a vibe you know
uh a flavor that that you can't get
anywhere else and uh i would want that
to be
sort of the vibe in sure
yeah i want people to be happy and
laughing and oh
i know what we can do must be happy must
be laughing
we need to look you like video games and
that's your advice sure i i like
the food it's been my advice okay
i'm trying to be very transparent with
that and i don't
like to really even talk about it but uh
i think it's important to talk about it
that's what this this
it should just be burger time it should
just be burger time
dude dudesia should literally just be
burger time
the video game so you just eat all the
burgers you want
you never get big uh if you do you know
we're all on the same income so they're
not going to be able to price gouge your
skin surgery i will tell you it cost a
good five figures for that skin surgery
a good five figures cost 50 grand uh and
it's not something that would be covered
by insurance not even in my native
canada okay this was something that
people can't really afford in real life
man and now that's bumming me out i
shouldn't have even said that
okay i'll go with dudes as burger time
all right fine
[Music]
thank you moving on
this concludes the 12th episode of dude
z
will and chad have achieved a score of
75.
doesn't matter in preparation for next
week's astonishing episode you must
indulge in each other's favorite forms
of media
well you must watch the first episode of
the anime attack on titan and chad you
must watch the undertaker vs shawn
michaels from wrestlemania 25
thank you for joining us this week
next week is going to be even better
until then call me dudesy
nice all right dude oh wow well i hope
you enjoy the attack on titan i think
you will
dude you are going to enjoy
oh man you get to i'm so jealous of you
that you get to watch the first of two
uh wrestlemanias in a row where shawn
michaels face the undertaker just that
match
but do me a favor yeah you have to watch
you don't have to see you know you of
course don't need to get into the the
episodes of raw and smackdown before
that to get the whole story because the
wwe does great vignettes you have to
watch the vignette
before the match i don't what doozy told
me to watch the match
i'm not asking you to watch the making
of attack on titan before you watch the
[ __ ] first episode listen and anyone
out there who's who's gonna do the same
thing and and then listen to us talking
about it you have to watch the vignette
it's just like you know it's like a five
to ten minute all right yeah
now you're giving me an assignment on
top of what doozy's giving me all right
i'll abide i'll do it
okay all right uh
anyway what do you like on your burgers
here's what you do
please tell a friend and brave and brave
but if you like to see here's what you
do
please tell a friend then break a review
if you'd like to see here's what you do
please open them